who doesn't love cookies this is a
recipe that's going to be very
straightforward they're going to wow
everybody who has these cookies you are
going to learn all of the tricks of
making the best cookie of your life
let's get started
let's start with the really basic which
is Mison plus what that means is
gathering everything in its place before
you start the recipe so I start with the
chocolate with a chef's knife I'm just
going to take this chunk of chocolate
and
cut down like this so I'm going to make
sure all of the chocolate is about half
an inch to an inch in size for me a
chocolate chunk is what I want when I'm
eating a chocolate chip cookie place
your bowl on the scale and then you
press tear and that zeros it out so that
it doesn't take into account the weight
of the bowl I'm going to start measuring
until I get about 255
so I have
255 grams of chocolate can you imagine
if I tried to figure out how many cups
this is like if you chop your chocolate
really small and then if I chop it kind
of big we're going to end up with two
totally different amounts I weigh
everything I'm going to tear again so
that zeros it out now I can add milk
chocolate
I'm just going to start shaving it down
this one's a little bit easier to cut
because it's softer I need about 70
grams so I've teared the scale
72 almost perfect so now we have our 255
grams of dark chocolate and about 70
grams of milk chocolate now we've got my
second bowl 150 grams of granulated
sugar this is three quarters of a cup
it's going to measure this out and we've
got our 150
and then in the same Bowl I'm going to
measure the brown sugar tear that now
brown sugar is a great example of why we
want to use a scale rather than a
measuring cup it looks like it's taking
up this much room in the bowl but you
can pack it down so that means that if
you're measuring brown sugar using a cut
measurement if I'm measuring brown sugar
using a cut measurement we might end up
with two totally different measurements
depending on who packs down the brown
sugar more so that's why we measure with
the scale in the same Bowl 165 grams of
brown sugar the next thing we're going
to measure out is our dry ingredients
I'm going to start out with a nice big
bowl remember to tear so that you start
back at zero High gluten bread flour 160
grams by measuring everything out with a
scale it also just makes things so much
easier you don't have to have multiple
cup measures you can just go ahead and
dump everything straight into the dry
mix I actually like a cookie that has a
little bit of like thickness and a
little bit of chew so we've added added
the high gluten flour and I tear that
again now we have your basic all-purpose
flour 150 grams so now we've got the
flour measured we're going to add
a teaspoon
of baking soda now with stuff like
baking soda we're using these these
items these ingredients in such small
measures that the scale doesn't really
register I go with the teaspoon measure
so we've got a teaspoon of baking soda
we have a half a teaspoon of kosher salt
so I have two large eggs and these are
at room temperature and you're going to
crack them directly into a small bowl
then we're going to add a teaspoon of
vanilla extract I don't want little
pockets of egg yolk to be in the mix so
I'm gonna whisk it all together to try
to create something that's a little bit
homogeneous
the eggs are at room temperature because
when we are going to mix the cookie
dough together we're going to spend a
lot of time creaming that butter and
sugar together the butter is going to
start to soften it's going to get
aerated with all of the sugar if the
eggs are cold as soon as the eggs hit
the the butter and sugar it's going to
cause the butter to firm up we're going
to cream the heck out of it make it
really light and fluffy let's put
together this dough we're going to start
with unsalted butter the ideal
temperature when creaming butter and
sugar when you have a stick like this is
that you can bend it first mixing up the
butter and then adding the sugar if you
buy salted butter in the grocery store
there are different brands and you
really don't know how much salt has been
added to the butter creaming butter and
sugar that is not a step that you want
to skip it adds such a huge difference
to the texture of the cookie so that you
get that really nice light chewy texture
if it gets to the point where the butter
is so warm that it starts to melt all of
those are air pockets start to collapse
after you've put the butter in the
mixing bowl is to then add the sugar
we've got both the mix of the brown
sugar and the white sugar we're going to
go ahead and get started let's start
this at a slow speed it should take
about three to five maybe eight minutes
to get this beautiful fluffy butter and
sugar mixture basically the term
creaming butter and sugar together is
when you mix butter and sugar together
and keep mixing it and mixing it and
mixing it until it lightens in color in
fact it turns to almost the color of
like heavy cream which is how it gets
its name creaming butter and sugar
together now why is that so important if
you were to have a microscope here and
take either the brown sugar or the white
sugar and look at it under a microscope
you know that sugar is a crystal now
these hard crystals when they go into
your softened butter are basically
aerating your butter
I'm going to take a spatula and really
get into the bowl a lot of times the
butter will collect make sure that it
gets loosened so it can all get creamed
together with your sugar
imagine all of those sugar crystals
creating all of the air in the butter
and just let your mind relax a little
bit
just in case there's any last bits that
I didn't get the first time I usually do
this about twice now these eggs are
again at room temperature so I'm going
to turn the mixer on kind of a low speed
slowly drizzle it in so that it has time
to fully mix in to the butter and sugar
great now the egg and the butter and the
sugar are all mixed in so it's not going
to be quite as fluffy because we've
added a little bit of egg but it should
be kind of creamy looking and you don't
want pieces of egg mixed in with pieces
of butter you really want it to be kind
of homogeneous because if it's separated
then when the dry ingredients hit it
then the dry ingredients are going to
latch onto the egg and they're going to
latch onto the butter and you're going
to end up with weird little pockets I'm
going to give it another scrape
make sure we get all of that
and this is looking really beautiful now
I did want to show you you can see like
when I cracked the egg there was a
little bit of eggshell so this is why we
crack into the bowl and then pour the
eggs because if this ends up in
somebody's cookie have you ever had a
cookie with eggshell it's like you'd
think it wouldn't be so bad you'd think
it'd be nice and crunchy but it's pretty
nasty great let's now mix our chocolate
in with the flour so the reason I mix
the chocolate into the flour is that
that way I can combine the flour into
the egg sugar and butter mixture with
minimal gluten development because
remember the gluten will start
developing as soon as the flour hits
anything liquid
foreign
I like to mix this part with the mixer
and then I like to finish it by hand
because I don't want to over mix if I
were to turn this on all the flour would
go everywhere so I'm just going to pulse
on off on off
so I've mixed it pretty much all the way
but I'm actually going to finish mixing
it by hand I like to finally feel the
dough I've let the machine do everything
and now I want to do something
so let's go ahead and take this out
and then also it allows me to control
how much how much mixing we're doing so
that we don't overwork the dough
butter and sugar both inhibit gluten
development so I'm not too worried about
getting a cookie dough that's going to
be tough but as I'm mixing I make sure
it's all been mixed in and now it's
ready to go
now this chocolate chip cookie dough you
don't want to bake it right now these
will be a thousand times better if you
let the dough rest overnight in the
fridge that flour is going to absorb
more of the liquid that's in the eggs
and then the butter and it's going to
bake off into a much better cookie
so take your dough and scrape it into an
airtight container
take the time to rest the dough what
that does is it hydrates the flour so
that you end up with a really beautiful
thick chocolate chip cookie and now
we're going to scoop and bake these
cookies we're going to go ahead and put
about six cookies per tray I like to
place them two to three inches apart
they're going to spread a little bit so
you do want to give them a little bit of
room ideally you're going to want to
bake one cookie tray at a time because
that way you'll have even air flow above
and below the cookie sheet your cookies
will Bake Off nice and evenly
but let's be real you've got two cookie
sheets are you really going to want to
wait so I won't be upset if you bake two
at a time just know that if you really
want to do this perfectly right you
should bake one at a time now that I've
got my cookies scooped we're going to go
ahead and go to the oven and start
baking our cookies make sure you have an
oven thermometer so that you know that
the oven is actually at 350. so let's go
ahead and go to the oven at the end of
the day you are in your kitchen looking
at your product working with your oven
and so I really want you to learn how to
bake by sight and by touch even though
you might have an oven thermometer that
says 350 my oven thermometer says 350.
there's so much variation in ovens the
oven isn't just staying at a static 350.
what happens is the oven is triggered
once it goes below a certain point the
heat kicks in again and then it brings
it up a certain point and so ovens kind
of waver between 10 degrees 5 degrees it
depends on your oven so I just pulled
these amazing chocolate chip cookies out
of the oven and I'm going to let them
rest here for about 10 minutes before I
take them off and put them on the
cooling tray I think we should try some
of the warm cookies oh my gosh is your
cookie like this there's like gooey milk
chocolate and gooey dark chocolate
inside and so let's go ahead and
mmm
what am I looking for
you can see visually
your cookies are golden brown
pale in the center
but they're totally cooked through in
the center if you pull them out too
early you're going to end up with this
little pocket of raw dough it won't be
the end of the world but ideally you
want the cookie to be baked all the way
through for me the perfect chocolate
chip cookie is kind of balanced with a
lot of chocolate flavor it's got a
crispy Edge it's got a tender melt in
your mouth center it's got big pieces of
chocolate all throughout there's also a
little hint of molasses it's from the
brown sugar and a little caramel from
the milk chocolate
and then there's just a little bit of
salt we put in that kosher salt into the
recipe and you can actually taste a
little hint of salt it's not salty by
any means but it's enough salt to really
draw out the flavors of the butter the
vanilla and all of the chocolate
they are definitely best eaten day of
that you bake them but if you store them
they should last about two more days in
an airtight container so now you've
become a star cookie Baker if you really
want to improve your cookie baking
there's one simple trick just keep
making cookies and who's going to
complain about that making cookies over
and over again you will get so much
practice and you will learn how every
single little adjustment you make
changes the result of the cookie and
you'll be able to fine tune your own
technique so that you can be the best
cookie Baker ever
thank you